hey what's up guys my name is Hoshino
welcome to episode 29 of 20 game
programming in Java
okay so last oh by the way I sort of I
bought like an an SSD and a bunch of RAM
as well because I was next to the
computer place and um I sort of
reinstalled Windows so onto that SSD you
know so I that's probably why I still
got this this background and um so I
don't I don't know if I've got I don't
even have paint.net yet do I damn it
that's gonna be a problem isn't it I
wish you'd made it for this episode but
um yeah so if there's something wrong
with my computer or something then uh
that's that bad that is the reason um
but other than that should be slightly
false oh yeah I actually picked up um
Ram is ridiculously cheap now I had four
gigs of RAM in my desktop because I
built it like two and a half years ago
actually about two years ago but um yes
I'm sorry I only put popped in a four
gigs of ddr3 RAM into it but um what
happened was I was pick up the SSD and I
was like well how much is RAM now and
I'm like ah and they're like well we can
get you eight gigs four gig sticks -
four gigabytes sticks for 41 dollars and
I was like yes thank you so now my
lovely computer has um 12 gigs of RAM in
it so right there so um that's right
that's ridiculous amount but and you
guys might be like you know why the hell
are you using that mushroom you don't
need it but I kind of do actually
because I do a lot of video work and
actually three it's pretty rendering and
stuff like that and and that stuff eats
up RAM like a little rabbit because
rabbits ate a lot anyway so let's let's
get back into this that's just basically
my life history for the last week in
case any of you weren't we had a we
had this little thing in a it works
items I had to reinstall Java or
everything on this computer it was kind
of embarrassing I actually I've been a
web browser and um I try to go I try to
go to like a website and it tells me
that I don't have Java installed and I'm
like oh yeah that's right gonna go got a
good go I have to go to Java come and
get that get that I get that Java
goodness into this computer but um yes
that was cool I don't know why Windows 7
doesn't come with Java actually I almost
it almost everything needs Joe
so yeah that is weird but uh yeah but
alas this is this is this works which is
awesome um it was surprisingly easy to
install as well I just want to cover one
thing on installing Java I actually
think that I used to have to go to here
and go to advanced system settings in
our environment variables actually go to
the path thing hit edit and add the Java
Runtime environment into the path but I
didn't actually have to do that this
time which was which was interesting so
that might have changed I they might do
it automatically now I'm not sure what
happened there but I could I could debug
and run programs fine without actually
having to add the Java stuff into that
environment in right environmental
environment variable I know what's what
is it called I got this right into that
environment variable in system variables
and path like you would have to normally
so I'm not sure but a good thing is it
works but if it stops working then I
guess I'll know why okay so now that's
out of the way um we sort of made most
of our buttons work except for actually
sorry we made none of our buttons work
except for exit but our the main thing
that's we're gonna cover today is making
our play button work um I don't think
I'll cover options and help at all bomb
unless you guys really want me to
because I mean not self-explanatory I
mean we we made options and help button
we made like an options dialog and
everything earlier so I'm sure you guys
could just figure out to link the two
I might link the two if I can be
bothered in this episode but add them
the main topic today is gonna be making
our play button actually work so let's
get into that the first thing I want to
do is let's open up our launcher class
and obviously this is where the buttons
actually do something so at the moment
we've got it printing out play but let's
just think for a moment what do we want
to happen when we hit that play button
essentially what we want to do is when
we hit that play button we want this
launcher to just basically destroy
itself we want to close we want a new
window to open up with our game and we
also want to load in the resolution that
we set in that XML document so
essentially we want to do the same thing
that we do
in this deprecated draw methods method
that we had before we actually created a
custom mantra so here we had this is
basically the essential code that we
want to put into here so that's let's
deal with that let's control exit let's
actually no let's just control say it'll
copy it into um into here and it is as
simple as that now a few things a few
things won't work the the deal is that
we we can't exactly dispose this frame
so to speak and the reason we can't that
if we if we try to dispose our frame
what will happen is it will crash and
the reason it will crash you'll find is
because we get an illegal set accepting
on our buffer now the reason is we're
using um just get out of this we're
using a canvas we're using a buffer
strategy and what happens is we we've
closed our window but we we haven't like
destroyed the buffer strategy so the way
we can do that is we can make sure that
our render menu method actually throws
an illegal set exception now we've never
actually done a throws I don't think
ever in our in this series so now is a
good time to probably explain it the
deal is if you if you've actually let's
this is what I want to do I want to make
a new class right now in comm dot my
mine front we'll call it like example
and we'll call this one
our throws throw okay and here this will
be like a blank canvas for me to
basically I'm not literally a canvas but
a blank like the class for me to
actually show you guys all so I
downloaded the UM the in Duke in I got
the AE version that's probably why
actually but I got the UM indigo version
of Eclipse not the Helius on that I had
before so one thing you'll notice is the
font is like Eclipse classic now I don't
know I I I do sometimes these eclipses
classic that's actually
same the only difference for me that it
poses as difference in font for the card
but um yeah so it'll actually look like
a clips classic card now but I don't
know why I don't know why maybe it's cuz
it's the AE I just realized that this is
Java AE as well I probably should have
downloaded that version because I don't
have it needed but um yeah so the font
will be also different so yeah okay so
it's like the latest version of Eclipse
um so let's let's not demonstrate our
throat if we try to do something let's
just call this well let's just quickly
make a load image method right so what
basically what we essentially want to do
is let's just load an image into our
buffered this is completely example guys
okay so don't don't don't copy this code
down just sit there and listen and if
you already know what a throwing thing
is and I'm sorry you might want to fast
forward I don't know but the thing is I
get tweets all the time saying it's
great that you explained this but you
didn't explain this and I'm determined
from here point onwards to completely
cover 100% of the code that I type so if
you if you know what a throw is fine but
there is I guarantee you there is at
least one person watching this video
probably about a hundred people watching
this video who have no idea what throws
means all right so just just chill okay
so buffered image equals null for now
and let's just import this quickly
and basically what what you'll see is
that if we try to make both of the image
equal a image i whoops image IO dot read
and let's just go through the class yeah
class dot get resource and let's just
say that it is in I don't know string
dot text whatever yeah well we're trying
to grade that we're trying on sort of
load an image and probably be like App
Engine e but doesn't matter because it's
just an example and we try to do this
and it comes up with an error and says
that you know doesn't we've got an error
here because there's you know this this
throws an exception so we'll come in
here and you'll see that we've actually
every time that we have this thing where
we have to try and catch up we've got to
we've got to um what we call it we've
got two options
God's around the trying cash which is
the option that we usually take all
we've got an ad throws declaration
Nellis if we hits around with try and
catch you'll do the standard thing that
we've done about a million times and
that is it'll try to do this and it
fails gonna cash an exception but there
is actually another way and the other
way is that we can add a throws
declaration and you'll see that in the
method on the top after the actual
method name and parameters before the
obviously before the curly bracket it
will say that this throws that type of
exception in IO and it put out put
exception all right now you guys might
be like oh well why don't I just always
do that I mean that sort of avoids try
and catch doesn't it I no longer have to
use try and catch it's just this is
easier my code looks cleaner it's
awesome no not exactly because whenever
you want to call that load image so
let's just make let's just pretend that
we've got okay let's just okay if we've
got a a constructor so every time we
create a new instance of this class is
gonna run the constructor code and if we
want to okay let's just load all our
images what during startup let's change
this to load images for no apparent
reason
so public void load images we want to
load our images every time we run the
Frog class if you type as you would
normally load images then you will find
that hey it doesn't work it says there's
an arm hammer there's an unhandled
exception now you can I'm just loving it
is you can add another throws
interpolation which is completely
pointless but um the thing is you're
avoiding using try and catch here but
you will still have to try and catch
this card right here okay that's that's
the main sort of thing so you will
stroke you will still have to try and
catch an illegal state exception in our
other example but an i/o exception here
so you can see that that works you will
still have to my door just mysteriously
open whether I'm contract out I'm not
actually I'm kidding but um the door did
open by itself which is weird probably
wind it anyway so the fact is you know
we've we've let me just kind of stuff
we've we've avoided using a try and cash
here but whenever we want to run this
entire method will have to use a try and
cash right now
that's how throwable stuff works that's
how everything dries I'm gonna be right
back I'm gonna close my door so I don't
as the kids are saying these days BRB
actually never say that I actually I'm
sort of it like a person my door just
opened again what was going on okay
hopefully that weren't happening ever
again my window was open so that's
probably why but um I'm actually the
kind of person here in instant messaging
and chat and stuff I never um I never
actually used like what do you call them
I do some I do sale all sometimes but I
say that in real life as well so was it
so weird
I don't know anyway but the point is
that um I never used like acronyms I
never go BRB or what else is there w eh
you I don't know what about you I
actually I fish I type out the entire
sentence and I always from at it I'm
always grammatically correct when I and
spelling wise as well I never taught you
just as in like the letter U I always
tried why are you so I'm I'm that's kind
of person which is why I don't say BRB
but I just did then which is cool
actually say acronyms in real life more
than I do in chat which is a interesting
I'm sure a lot of you guys are saying
cool story bro and that's a it's very
nice but um anyway so I hope you guys
now understand how Roy works if you
throw at one place you're gonna have to
handle it and basically the reason that
we even have to do something for this
method is because the in the original
source code it's got this method right
this dot raid method there's a class
called image IO IO and there's a public
static void I don't know I don't know if
it's void but anyway void method called
braid and it is throwing and
when you call it an i/o exception all
right
it's whoops barrelling it is doing this
and that's the reason that we actually
have to do this because there's a method
called that in the image higher class
doing that and obviously you would have
something like I don't know buffer
damage whatever anyway point is that is
how that's how it works so let's just go
ahead and make this code vaguely vaguely
work real quick so that it doesn't do
any errors and let's just close that so
that is that is how throes work I hope
that I helped some of you guys out um so
the others won't get mad at me in the
comments for no apparent reason just
this okay so let's get back into this so
the reason is I don't really want to set
up a trying cache method okay in fact I
I don't want to set up a trying cache
method because the deal is we've already
got one and it's kind of getting
annoying so instead of setting up a try
and cash method what I want to do is
instead is actually make this throw an
illegal set exceptions so that nice and
cleanly in my so that basically I don't
have to surround this entire method in a
try and cash you want to do a try and
catch if one part of your method
involves basically if it's it's
completely a matter of opinion I'm
almost 100% convinced that there is no
impact on performance if you use throws
or if you use thing so I don't think
that if if I just tried and cache this
and then throw it here and then handle
it somewhere else I don't think there
would be any impact on performance if
you guys if you got my name advanced
guys are wondering about that I'm not
I'm there's no way back on performance I
can say if I say that all right so when
we call our render method we're gonna
have to try and catch that and even
though it doesn't tell us - so let's try
and catch our what is it illegal legal
state I can't type today illegal State
exception e
and let's just print the staff
transparency nature but um let's just
print system dot out sitting
system dot out dot print line we can do
print doesn't matter print line starts
it on a new line makes it kind of
convenient I guess handled handled baby
oh yeah now we're talking so basically
what happens is when we hit play we will
get handled and the deal is it's still
going which is concerning me because it
shouldn't be the deal is it's still it's
still it's still doing it because um
we're still sort of I guess in this in
this wall running loop and the the deal
is when we the deal is when we close
when we finally close our this window we
want to it's got its own it's got its
own like thread right it's go soon it's
a it's got its own Start menu in stop
menu and it's got a sewing thread which
we call the menu thread we want to get
rid of that fritter we want to call the
stop menu thing once we actually you
know hit play but not before that
because what will happen is if if we if
we try and dispose that the deal is we
can't actually use this thread to close
itself because if you try and run a
closed thing on a thread that's
currently running it will not close
because it stopped working
that makes no sense at all but I'm gonna
try and illustrate it basically
basically I don't care if this isn't
100% correct by you I don't know every
what to call you you are you I don't
know Java followers of the sacred order
of being politically correct in Java the
the basic deal here is that if we've got
a thread I don't have page out now so
I'm powerless if we have a thread and
I'm using my mouse to draw I should
probably get a tablet a little traveling
right right there but it's too far away
if we've got a thread and this is called
our menu thread and we'll just call it
red so that equals menu right and then
we've got another thread
let me get back to my black color it's
still freakin red what okay
I'm Niles pointless why they I have two
colors if you can't freaking switch
between them that sucks
alright so we've got another one oh I
guess it's right mouse button
oh cool paint has evolved since I last
use it and if we've got another thread
which we'll call our game thread which
will be blue right if we try and close
if we try and close this thread so we
want to close it we can't because it
will execute this command and then
freeze because it's gone it's closed the
thread there's nothing in the thread to
tell it to actually close it can't do
anything else it's dead so what we need
to do is we need to use this thread to
come in here and be like let's close
this thread so this thread safely closed
closes and there's another thread to
execute the close command for this
thread alright
does that make sense I hope it does if
it does leave a comment I'll try and
explain it okay if someone leaves a
comment and genuinely does not
understand this then I will make a video
dedicated to explaining this because I'm
pretty sure that I've explained Acker
I've explained it you know in a way that
all of you can understand so um I bet
you all the comments for a bit like I
have no idea what you're talking about
so that I'm waste time making your video
but the point is that you need something
else to kill this okay this threads
threads and Java cannot commit suicide
okay
they need someone to kill them okay as
dark as that sounds it's reality alright
so now that you're completely uh you
know I don't scared and probably hiding
on your under your bed um you understand
how threads work so let's get back into
this so in other words we need something
else to close our thread so the deal is
there's sort of a big deal here right
and the deal is that we want our
basically when we hit new Ron game we
want this code to close our previous
thread however however we run into
another problem and this is this is what
I like to refer to as the problem of
instances okay the deal is we cannot
actually tell it to do something from
this class because to do that as you
would imagine this don't menu this stop
menu is not a static a static method so
I'd imagine that all of you are probably
thinking oh well don't worry channa all
you have to do is hit up launcher
launcher or whatever you can call
whatever you want equals new launcher
and I don't know what what we had it set
to before actually we should probably
get rid of that display thing and then
you import that and you're like yeah it
works but no it doesn't because the
thing is when we make a new instance of
this launcher class we are creating
another launcher all right it's not
closing that launcher that already
exists it's closing an entirely new
instance of that launch I hope you guys
are understanding this because you
better be because this can't can't be
any more simple than this okay I'm
actually feeling a very good explaining
mood today so you know take it well lost
um just cuz I'm sick of frickin comments
of people saying you didn't explain this
you did explain that now no one no one
has the right to say that because I
because I'm explaining up absolutely
everything
oh all right sir no I want a biggest
science thank you very much to think of
the better right mm-hm
if you're not a man no you don't I'm I'm
not gay by the way just I just I just
wanted to put that out there real quick
because I'm someone left a comment
asking I'm not homosexual
all right I'm completely heterosexual I
am attracted to women okay deal over
good I hope it is because I just just
didn't want to you know keep that option
open at all all right so let's get
back into this that's completely random
on earth but I'm sorry but let's pretend
this so what am i doing again what was
the problem
oh yeah instances so this is what I call
and there is a text to learn the problem
and you can quote me on this of
instances and that ladies and gentlemen
is a registered trademark so don't go
ahead stealing that so the problem of
instances don't probably probably
already taken that so but we've got this
problem of instances right and the
problem that we have right now is that
we where's my brush we've got one
instance of an application now how do we
call that when we hit up the new
launcher we created an instance of that
so we've got an instance of the launcher
class which we'll call l1 right this is
the first instance of launched class
this is the one that we just that
displays this this is the one that looks
like that this is what displays our
launcher this is what functions as a
launcher now we've called that only once
if we're going to display you'll see
that we call that launcher we create a
new instance of that launched class now
we're saying in run game we need to use
a launcher and what we want what we
probably want to do is we want to start
this thread and then immediately we want
to close the old the old Fred so we want
to go launcher don't stop menu right no
wrong because what that does is it
creates another instance of Oh almost
failed there of our launch class and
then with that instance it closes it all
right it stops that thread it does not
stop this this is this is still happily
running and I cannot write with mice
it's this is still happily running while
this is dead dead so we need to stop
this instance so we need to somehow
retrieve this instance
in another class and kill it all right
we want to get a gun and shoot it
basically maybe not with a gun there
maybe with a simple exit stop thread
thing but so that's a deal right and we
can do that thankfully there's always a
way all right
I'm actually getting kind of tired of
people asking me you know is this
possible in Java is this possible in
Java Java is a programming language
which means that whatever you want is
possible all right
to an extent obviously to basically to
the extent of hardware capabilities so
is it possible to render a billion
polygons on the screen with out using
the graphics card in Java no no okay
no but then again you know it's not only
possible any other programming language
or any way but the deal is that uh you
know if you had the hardware for that
then yet it is possible it is if you had
the freaking uh I don't know some kind
of supercomputer then yeah it probably
would be but then again that's not you
know that's not javis fault that's the
computers fault sir yeah but uh anything
is pretty much possible so the deal is
we want to sort of create an instance so
I'm gonna do this in this class and
there is no that I want to make an
instance of the launcher a what that
would be one and only the one and only
instance of the launch Corral class will
be created in the display class reason
because we primarily use it in the
display class right here so the first
thing I want to do is let's open up our
launcher and you can see that if you
this display don't start thing we don't
use it actually so let's get rid of that
and let's just check that it sort works
and you can see that it does completely
work we still get our help us with our
options and exits still works awesome so
now if you if you just put your mouse
over this you can see that it's not
highlighting display because we're not
using you anywhere so it's completely
remove that parameter and we'll actually
have to go into display and remove that
parameter from here as well and we will
also have to go onto our options and
remove this
and the same with right over here so now
we should be completely error-free yeah
we are got a lot of warnings for those
all right I'm gonna go and fix each one
of them right now
so let's come in here and all we sort of
really want to do here is let's create
okay so we've got okay so the deal is we
start a new launcher but let's not do it
that way all right let's do it a
different way let's first of all we
don't even need this display anymore so
let's get rid of that and I sort of like
checking that everything's working
before I go ahead and spend a bunch of
time and it's obviously said it's
handled wasn't working and spend a bunch
of time on card and then figure out that
it doesn't work um so let's come up here
and let's make a new launcher variable
so launcher launcher equals null all
right in fact we probably don't even
have to set that at all
let's just put it like that it'll it'll
automatically equal null for us and we
want to make it static so static
launcher launcher that's it so we're
done now let's make a method and I want
to sort of make this under the display
constructor I just as a general rule
like to have the discipline the
constructor of a class as the very first
like thing so before any methods I want
to have a constructor first year and
half two it's perfectly okay to put
another method here called you know this
works in front of it you can see that
does not do any doesn't generate any
errors but it's just my style I guess I
don't like I like to have the
constructor as the very first method in
the class so let's make a public static
method that will call launcher sorry
sorry launcher actually gonna call get
instance but um we'll set the type to
the launcher so as you know there's met
there's many different types of methods
there's the void type which means it
doesn't return anything and pretty much
any other type that isn't void means
that it returns something so in this
case an integer it returns an integer a
double it returns a double a boolean it
returns a boolean a launcher returns
let's come on guess hopefully that's
enough time returns a launcher instance
it returns a launcher type object it
returns a launcher object and you can
see the problem here is that it is let's
add a return statement so it's all it's
automatically returning launcher so
that's awesome
so now we've got a way to get launcher
but the thing is at the moment launcher
equals null so what we sort of want to
do is say that if if our current
launcher thing is equal to null then
let's basically create a launcher so if
it is equal to null then let's set
launcher equal to new launcher with the
parameter of zero of course and that
ladies and gentlemen is it all right
that's all we need to do so now if we
come into here sorry for coming to run
game and we want to end they want to end
our our thread all we have to do
actually to sum it let's come down down
here make sure it works instead of
creating a new launcher all we want to
do is we want to get the instance now I
probably should called it get launched
for instance or something but um I've
just called to get instance because we
haven't actually okay I probably will
use this method sometime in the future
so let's quickly refractor it so all
shift our or right-click refactor rename
and basically what that will do is it
will rename all see you consider its
renaming this as well because it's got a
box around it it's renaming everything
in the in the whole project that is
called you know that is that so that you
don't have to you know copy and paste
the new name everywhere so get
launcher instance that's it so you can
see that it automatically fixed it up
here get launched for instance so let's
just hit run and you can see that it
works perfectly awesome exit so if we go
into run game let's make a private void
here called stop thread stop menu thread
that's probably more precise and what
all this will do is let's go to display
and because we've obviously made our get
in get launcher instanced static we can
use it so display dot get launched
launcher instance dot stop menu that's
all we want to do so
let's come in here and let's type a stop
menu thread now it was my choice
entirely just to put it in here okay you
could probably put that code in there
but I just didn't like this for
non-parent reason just because I'm Nate
and I like to keep stuff organized all
right so let's sell issuing this out now
let's hit play and check that out now I
handled it doesn't even appear anymore
it uh
it's gone because if we go into here and
we check out run and so while running
let's just have this print our system
two out dot print line running menu
running and again if you know me I like
putting a sign and Knox everyone so menu
running you can see that menu is running
we had play and well it's not running
anymore yeah awesome so that's that is
how the that is how the cookie crumbles
in Java so that's brilliant so what we
sort of want to do now is make I guess
our game work and yeah so we've closed
this and it's coming to here so we hang
on hang on let me just close this
alright so let's get rid of this and so
the deal is that and we did the same
thing here you know if that equals null
then let's create a buff strategy so
it's similar to what we did here right
all right cool
okay so we lower the configuration we
dispose of the frame and then we run the
game and by running the game we close
that method all right cool so we start
the game I'm actually curious as to why
our game doesn't work at the moment play
it's sort of not just playing any
graphics adapter let's go to display
it's probably because we are not
rendering look at that play yay look at
that oh that mouse is not working like
basically at all Wow okay I got to be we
have a bit of fixing to do on our hands
well it's completely don't mind sorry
okay let's come in here one thing one
thing that I was thinking about the
other day was why did I put the discard
in here like that's completely unlit
it's not even in the wall it's it's I'm
not sure so let's just grab this let's
cut it and then let's put it to the tick
method all right so it's as simple as
that we've put all of our stuff into the
tick method so that it basically happens
it's kind of like our controls you know
our controls are affected in the tick
method so why isn't our mouse let's set
that mouse to be affected in it the tick
method a bunch of you guys were actually
asked me why don't why did I call this
tick it would be traditional to call
this update because what the tick method
does is it updates our game right so
whatever we want to update we put into
the update method I I don't know why I I
guess cuz not always uses tick I've sort
of started to use that but it doesn't
make sense like clock ticking I just I
don't know why I just I don't I don't
like the word update in this
for some reason it just seems weird
private for what update like updates
like you know it ticks it updates but I
don't know I just like tick more I just
like the word tick but basically this is
you would call this the updates here for
the update and the render so this
updates the game state and the actual
the I guess the thinking behind the game
the the logic behind again the game
logic and this renders the actual
graphics to the screen so yeah let's run
this see what it does to us alright so
we've got a working Mouse now awesome
where are we we are let me come back to
where we are here we are I can't find us
this mouse is getting really annoying by
the way and kind of obnoxious where are
we all right let me just I lost us hey
there we go so you can see that the
mouse does indeed work except for the
part where it wants off a screen of
course might fix that I can have a go
fixing that now but I don't know my
opinion is actually there's no way
there's no good way to fix it inside I'm
just you know Java so I don't know but
um let's come in yeah we I'm gonna do
that now but uh yeah cuz usually I just
use like old obj jail to actually grab
females um I don't know we'll deal with
that in the future but um I guess that's
pretty much it for today let's come in
here and let's let's let's make the
options thing work
all right so whoa what happened so if we
hit the options button we want to
dispose that frame and we were no let's
not to suppose that frame actually let's
keep that frame running and let's create
a new uses of the options things or
options create seeing your options ooh
that is problematic
why are coz options and Harris damn it
okay we'll have to fix this up right now
then alright so why does it have to do
that all right so let's not have it
inherit let's make a we can't extend
launcher anymore unfortunately let's
make a new jframe and let's I can
actually make it an icon and a new
jpanel have to do everything all over
again because we want to I I don't want
to have like a custom options thing I
want to have a GUI options thing so
jpanel window
no panel window equals new jpanel and
hopefully that's all we need to do so
frame dot set visible to true obviously
frame dot set default close operation to
jframe dot exit close we could actually
have this let's do that let's have this
extend a frame so that we don't need
this stuff and is that it the Spurs and
config so we're gonna make an instance
of the configuration of o'clock class as
well that's fine
just import that as well and the mine
front one monthly Java security one or
whatever and well after dammit we donate
button width and height anymore do we
no oh yeah we kind of do a gal let's
just copy it then and put it into
options and its private and there we go
so let's come in here and run this run
this beast hit options and awesome it
comes up with a new thing and it's
resizable so let's fix it out real quick
frame I can't believe resizable it's
true by default
oh man it is that's kind of it's kind of
weird how I'm responsible it's true by
default should be false by default
because more often than not I guess
you'd want it not to be resizable okay
so not about none of our stuff is here
which is kind of annoying and why isn't
yeah should be here I mean we do draw
the buttons cuz we turn on I don't
actually add the window into our thing
so I should work now and the last did
gee that's annoying let's set for layout
to you bottle out of whatever we had
before
Oh actually no did we just have a new
boarder layout before probably not what
we had before
oh we just had set layout no I can
settle out and you brought a lout and I
think that's cool so yeah there we go
oh that looks weird let's get rid that
and said that's null oh I know obviously
we have to UM deal with that in a minute
but you can see that our our stuff works
right now actually it sort of works but
um it doesn't paint it so obviously we
need to win that pressures obviously we
need to repaint oh and we can't sorry
let's set default close operation to not
exit on clothes on clothes because we
don't wanted to we just want it to close
that window all right cool so I guess
the deal right now is we get rid of this
right here anymore but I guess the deal
right now is that we need to what was a
problem with ania we need to repaint sir
just repaint window one is a very paint
so that we don't get that problem of
stuff piled wrong early and let's set
that equal to that okay hit play and you
can see that we are at that resolution
indeed so that is the deal and we seem
to be functioning correctly which is
cool
oh that's kinda weird look at the floor
and everything huh
that is weird alright well that's pretty
much a lot of time for this time 42
minutes all right I wanna try and keep
these these episodes like you know like
a standard length like I guess the
standard length of up to a full episode
of a TV show
so about 42 minutes to 45 minutes I
guess um but yeah without a breaks for
now you know unless I happened to get
partnered somehow and and you guys will
have to watch pre-rolls in front of Maya
videos which would suck for you guys
kind of but it would be kind of cool for
me I guess oh but anyway so the deal is
we've got this we've got a functioning
options thing whoops I've got a
functioning options thing which
functions obviously and show you this
works quickly I don't even know if
that's a reasonable it is a bit yeah
okay that uh I guess you could call it
worked anyway let's set that back to
what it was a really just set it back to
800 by 600 all right so now we've got
this functioning thing and it seems to
be really cuz the Dollar Tree but for
the most part it sort of works and look
at our fps that's kind of dodgy so we'll
think of all that next week but for the
main part you guys should have go of
fixing that yourselves and that's pretty
much it so next week we'll fix
everything and hopefully what we'll do
next week if we have time is I actually
want to get back to the game stuff
because we have been doing this launcher
stuff for quite a long time and we
really do need to get back to doing our
awesome um actual game development you
know because we just had a long wreck
from that so what I want to do next week
is I want to start on level design and
collision detection so what I want to do
is instead of randomly generating a
level I actually want to create
different kind of different kinds of
blocks I want to create a world I want
to create collision detection and you
know we can see we could sort of see how
our games what comes together actually
becomes fun so I'm
that's really what I want to do next
week but in order for me to do that I
want you guys just to do one thing I
want you guys to like this video alright
all you have to do is hit the like
button and if this video reaches 100
likes by the end of the week
then I will next week start on level
design alright it's as simple as that
so hit did it hit the like button if you
liked the video I'm sure you did
I mean what's not to like this episode
was freaking awesome anyway I hope it
was umm but apart from that you know we
will get back to her we'll get back to
the game finally so make sure you hit
the like button favorite the video if
you liked it that much and yeah see you
guys next week so hit the like button
let's get to 100 likes and if we do love
lazar next week so yeah see you guys
later bye